My plan had
originally been to enlist in the Army
and then use that to pay for college.
Once I found out about QuestBridge
and the generous financial aid
the colleges like Yale have,
that sort of changed my plans.
I focused on QuestBridge
because the profile of students
that they described was exactly who I was.
It was nice to just have it established
through applying through QuestBridge
that I was first generation low income.
I wasn't trying to fit
into a mold of different activities
or things that weren't
even accessible in my high school.
It allowed me to present who I am more
than just what I've done academically.
The day I was accepted to Yale I was like,
Wait, no way, this is a prank.
And then I was like, Wait, no, it's not.
I'm running through my house.
And I'm like, Mom, Mom look,
you know, look
you kind of feel like, okay, I'm
going to be
the only one who's the first person
to go to college in their family.
The only one from a small town.
But when you get here, you see that
there's thousands of other people
with the same, same experience, you know?
The Quest Scholars network at Yale
has truly become my family.
Just knowing that everyone has gone
through similar things
as me is comforting.
It is a shared identity
that, you know, hundreds of students
come to campus having and the Quest Scholars
Network is a place for them
to build a little home within Yale.
It's been very valuable
in terms of finding a community
where I felt at home and not out of place.
I felt like I really found a place that I
fit in at, a sort of home away from home.
I've never felt,
you know, like I didn't belong here.
It is hard, but it's worth it
because Yale is the best thing
that's ever happened to me.